the right triangle's longest side is
called the hypotenuse
and it's this side here let's see the
longest one
i wish i were high on hotness
i wish i was high on pot noose
[Applause]
okay okay mr morrison's very funny it's
very funny but
let's get back to the lesson if you can
see the longest one
where it goes from this point that was
my joke i know man that was hilarious
of a triangle i've labeled them here a b
and c no but i mean i said that they
labeled anything
i said it say that they're i said it i
said that
please please mr jackson keep your
comments to yourself
thank you ah now the hypotenuse is
[Applause]
you really got me on that one oh so
great
oh oh principal martel principal martel
come here come here come here
uh tell principal martel what you said
troy oh uh
um she was talking about the hypotenuse
and i said i wish
i was high on pot noose
[Applause]
i'm sorry
he likes it principal martell is cool
that's a very funny principle martell
principal martel
i said that mr jackson that is enough
but i said it first oh uh mr iglesias mr
iglesias yes
come in come in yeah yes what's up
people's
fluffy comedian gabriel iglesias is
touring the local schools today for a
charity he's working on
tell him what you said tell me what you
said oh
i wish i was high on pot noose
oh my god that is clever that is good
very funny right
no thanks mr iglesias mr gracias uh i'm
your biggest fan
that was my joke uh you know it's not
really cool buddy to take credit for
other people's
jokes hey listen funny stuff i'm doing
this big tour right now
you want to see about maybe we could
talk about your opening i need an opener
oh um sure what do you think is that
okay
of course what
nice sorry meet you thanks so much like
richard pryor get over here man come on
he deserved it all right so across from
the longest side
is a 90 degree angle good thing i've got
a 90 degree
dangle yo stop it you will never be
troy why are you trying to be like troy
dick a two nerdy girl
so the hypotenuse
[Applause]
right here oh my god
good evening my fellow americans every
day our citizens improve the lives of
those around them
today we honor troy morrison now troy
was in a geometry class when his teacher
mentioned
the hypotenuse of a triangle troy said i
wish i was high hypotenuse
that really cracked me up and it cracked
up the rest of america too
so today i'm pleased to present troy
with the congressional comedy
medal of honor troy on behalf of the
entire country
i just want to uh thank you for your
fantastic
off-the-cuff line you are a true comedy
hero
thank you sir thank you and also mr
president i have uh something for you
what's that
oh my god yes
these are sold out i haven't been able
to get my hands on one of these thanks
troy
oh my goodness